foreign
[Music]
has taken a considered decision
to be a part of the coalition
to be with the United States to fight
terrorism
in all its forms
wherever it exists
I think that the country continues to
suffer from the terrorism that emanates
from the way in which the war on terror
was prosecuted in this country Musharraf
became a darling for the U.S he was very
close to George W bush he was lauded by
him through and through but the burden
of his decisions have been carried by
successive elected leaders and by the
Pakistani military
[Music]
foreign
is the big thing that he did before he
took over which was that he planned and
executed the kargil war in 1999 with
India that permanently damaged Pakistan
standing with its Western Partners but
also really eliminated the the chances
for any kind of reconciliation or
normalization in this region
believe me
[Music]